hey there and welcome to this pro flows
quick tip
i'm cameron and in this quick video i
want to show you
um a time saving hack for after effects
so whenever we start a new project it
always starts out like this we have a
blank canvas
and we typically have to go in we have
to start creating uh folders so we can
organize our assets
once we start importing them in so if i
go through here a lot of times i will
create folders
like maybe called an output folder i'm
going to have a comps folder
maybe inside that comps folder i'm going
to have additional folders like
pcs which i like to call precomps
that's how i abbreviate it i also have
things like
working comps i'm also going to have
other folders
like assets and maybe inside of that one
i'm going to put
footage maybe inside of footage i'm
going to put
pre-renders maybe also within that i'm
going to have something
for proxies
i'm also going to have assets for raster
images
for vector images the list goes on and
on and on
now a lot of times i will import files
and have a big mess and then have to
create this folder structure and start
dragging these
files into these folders but there's a
big time saver we can do
so that we have to do this every single
time so what you want to do is you want
to create
a file structure something like this
you can even create your first
composition so i'll just call this
composition output and let's say that
you know for me personally i like to
work
at hd tv 1080 24 i like to work at 24
frames a second i like to have a default
duration
between 5 and 10 seconds so we'll do 10
seconds black background i'll click ok
so we have a composition here so let's
save this
as a startup template and how do we do
that so all we have to do is we just
have to
save our project out to our computer so
we do that really quickly
and i've got it saved out and the next
important step is i go to my preferences
for after effects and i go down to this
preference called new project
and i click new project and i have to
enable this box
right here and after i enable it i want
to choose my project template
okay so i navigate to where my project
template is that i saved i
click it i say open there it is it's
set i'm going to click ok and then all i
have to do now is just quit after
effects and
restart it
now here after effects is starting back
up and watch what happens
as soon as i click on new project watch
what happens right here
i have my folder structure here already
i've got my output comp
already set up here it's my 1080p
24 frames per second i've got all my
comps set up in here i've got my assets
set up in here and boom i'm good to go
and that's it that's a it's a huge time
saver
every time you start up after effects
you're going to have a working
folder structure here ready to go if you
enjoyed this video i would invite you to
check out pro flows plus
for more videos just like this